If you ask me,
do you recommend this master in Autonomah?
If you don't know,
my master was called m. O. B,
Master of Management,
Organization,
Business and economics.
Yeah, big name, right?
Don't get me wrong.
Autonomah is one of the most prestigious
university in the whole country and was public.
So I can't complain.
And as I told you before,
my background in economics is zero.
I passed. I'm very happy about that
cause it was a personal challenge.
But this master was very confusing.
We have to change 3 times CD.
What is amazing in theory,
because in practice
they don't give you any assistance.
Like the whole organization
in the master is very difficult,
very complex.
Keep in mind
is an academic master is not an NBA.
But I swear
they try to make your life harder.
It shouldn't be that hard,
but they want
the main idea of this master is incredible.
We start in Barcelona,
we go to open up in Pompano
and then we go to Mayorca.
It sounds very nice,
right? But really
I don't know what it
they are doing wrong to make everything worse.
But thank god
I have many friends and we help each other
and we understood each other.
And this was the best part of the whole master
is making friends,
having experience,
and to overcome your own personal challenges.
This was for sure
my biggest lesson that I had in this master.